[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique en direct sur france 3
bourgogne nous sommes aujourd'hui à dix
semaines du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et à l'issue d'une
semaine encore nettement marquée par les
difficultés de françois fillon nous
avons choisi de parler de la droite de
son avenir et de sa vision de l'avenir
pour la france nous en débattons ce
matin avec nos trois invités à nerchio
bonjour vous êtes conseillère
départementale de côte-d'or et président
du groupe de la droite et du centre au
conseil municipal de dijon et vous
soutenez françois fillon généraux de
boulbon jours bonjour vous êtes
conseiller régional front national au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté et vous soutenez bien sûr marine
le pen maxime thibeault bon jour là je
vous êtes délégué national de votre
parti debout la france et vous soutenez
donc nicolas dupont aignan alors les
sondages se suivent et se ressemblent
depuis quelques jours françois fillon le
candidat de la droite et du centre
davies plombé par la sphère de l'emploi
présumé fictif de son épouse et de ses
enfants alors où va la droite c'est le
thème de cette émission à la chasse on a
de plus en plus l'impression qu'elle va
dans le mur la droite non avec françois
fillon
ça dépend de quoi on parle la droite non
elle va pas dans le mur elle a un projet
la sphère fillon c'est une chose c'est
la justice qui est saisie et qui fera le
nécessaire pour mettre fin à toute cette
histoire
mais la droite elle s'appuie sur un
projet qui élaboré depuis trois ans et
françois fillon porte un proche g qui
est est-ce qu'il est taillé voulons pas
ce programme du coup avec cette affaire
écouter les français aujourd'hui
n'attendent pas d'un candidat qu'il soit
l'homme où la femme providentielle les
français ils veulent un projet qui met
en oeuvre des réformes pour redresser la
france
la france elle est dans un état qu'on
connaît suite à cinq ans de gestion
socialiste désastreuse aujourd'hui il
faut de nouveau penser à l'emploi au
chômage à l'europe
voilà tout ce qui peut constituer et qui
constituent aujourd'hui notre projet le
journal du dimanche affirme ce matin que
le parquet national financiers s'apprête
à poursuivre les époux fillon ça vous
4 quand même c'est toujours inquiétant
mais pour l'instant ça fait tellement
deux semaines qu'on en parle
jour et nuit à croire qu'il se passe
rien d'autre dans le monde sont nés même
inquiétant je pense qu'il faut que la
justice fera son travail le parquet fera
son travail
moi j'espère en tout cas qu'il fera son
travail en prenant compte l'indépendance
des pouvoirs et qu'il s'appuiera sur les
règles de trois qui sont nécessaires
n'avaient pas l'impression que c'est le
cas aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui non
j'aimerais en être sûr françois fillon a
essayé de se relancer l'année dernière
et que sa conférence de presse est ce
qui vous a convaincu vous à mary 2 avant
de vous répondre je souhaiterais si vous
le permettez rendre un hommage à celles
et ceux qui nous protège au quotidien
c'est les ce sens qu'il n'y aurait pas
de sécurité de propriété il n'y aurait
pas d'état de droit
celles et ceux qui ont sauvé une petite
fille de 6 ans hier dans une voiture en
flammes à bobigny c'étaient ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui victimes de la violence
et de la haine des racailles
je veux bien sûr parler de nos policiers
gendarmes nos forces de l'ordre qui sont
aujourd'hui tristement abandonné et
trahi par un gouvernement coupable voilà
qui préfère finalement laissé libre
cours à son laxisme et favoriser les
racailles donc baqim hier ont ravagé
notamment la la gare routière de bobigny
moi je traiterai leur leur témoigner bas
tout notre soutien le soutien de marine
le pen et leur dire que avec marine
ils pourront réellement être respectés
considérés et surtout pouvoir faire leur
travail correctement et dignement
alors la question sur la question alors
vous parliez de la droite
alors je suis ravi monsieur sicot vous
m'ayez invités vous allez dire que je
n'ai pas de dose suis désolé et
d'ailleurs je revendique le front
national non plus alors non plus comme
un parti patriote républicain et
démocratique est un grand parti qui
entend rassembler tous les patriotes
d'où qu'ils viennent et quel qu'il soit
ensuite sur sur la sphère fillon puisque
c est ce qui nous a convaincu lundi pas
du tout et je pense qu'il l'a convaincu
personne aucun français en tout cas ces
scellés
remontées de terrain que j'ai notamment
dans l'yonne et surtout moi ce que
j'observe c'est une exaspération une
colère une incompréhension aussi et un
certain nombre d'adhérents des
républicains de militants qui se sentent
cocufié tout simplement qui sont allés
voter à la primaire et qui considèrent
que le candidat de la probité de la
morale publique on leur a vendu en fait
est une imposture
voilà est aujourd'hui le candidat fillon
ne peut certainement pas présenter son
projet présidentiel est totalement
disqualifié pour demander des sacrifices
aux français notamment sur les
l'étranger les 39 heures payées 35 sur
le démantèlement de la sécurité sociale
sur la hausse de la tva
quand on regarde les difficultés
aujourd'hui les français no 7 millions
de chômeurs no 9 millions de pauvres
c'est totalement inadmissible demander
des sacrifices tel est d'avoir des
pratiques et des comportements qui sont
totalement indécent alors nicolas dupont
aignan lui a critiqué françois fillon
cette semaine en disant qu'il prenait en
otage
l'élection présidentielle pourquoi ça
oui c'est pas marrant de son fait
le vrai problème en réalité cette
monsieur fillon est en train de prendre
en otage le lectorat de droite parce que
sa campagne est terminée
cinq candidatures n'a plus aucun sens la
campagne de monsieur fillon c'était la
droiture la vérité c'est l éthique en
politique est là en une semaine deux
semaines on a vu que monsieur fillon en
réalité c'est un emploi quasi fictif
parce que si sa femme avait vraiment
travailler on aurait eu des preuves à
l'attaché parlementaire quand ils
travaillent
vous savez on voit des preuves et là on
n'a aucune preuve de la réalité de son
travail est le vrai problème c'est que
aujourd'hui à la droite elle se trouve
orphelines et nicolas dupont aignan
avaient de son projet gaulliste car
nicolas dupont aignan est le dernier
candidat gaulliste à l'élection
présidentielle est présent pour dire à
cette droite mais vous savez il ya
encore une chance d'éviter la torre de
monsieur macro carlingue campagne la
candidature de monsieur fillon
c'est la victoire de monsieur macron et
c'est ça le vrai problème et moi je veux
pas que la gauche la gauche la gauche
financière de rothschild le candidat de
la finance en la personne de monsieur
macron gagne la france
car demain il s'agit de sauver les
français ils s'invitent il s'agit de
sauver les classes moyennes et
populaires qui sont en train de souffrir
par une politique qui est mortifère
depuis 30 ans et moi j'appelle les
électeurs de la droite les électeurs qui
sont aujourd'hui orphelins à rejoindre
le le projet patriotique le projet
républicain et gaulliste de nicolas
dupont aignan est en tout cas en train
de le voir on a le sénateur jean louis
masson avec 100 élus conseillers
régionaux conseillers départementaux et
mères qui ont signé une tribune pour
appeler les électeurs de droite à venir
rejoint nicolas dupont aignan et je vous
cache pas qu'il ya beaucoup de
parlementaires issus des républicains
qui nous disant secret moi j'ai compris
à l'élection présidentielle je voterai
nicolas dupont aignan voilà donc c'est
certain temps est regrettable c'est un
danger à la chance pour moi et je ne
vois pas de danger
les militants les sympathisants
républicains les sympathisants même du
centre
je les vois tous les jours je les côtoie
il ya pas si longtemps à la villette
nous étions quinze mille pour soutenir
françois fillon non les la droite n'est
pas orpheline la droite et le centre
n'est pas orpheline
je peux vous le garantir ils porteront
le projet françois fillon n'est pas
quelqu'un qui écrit un projet sur un
coin de table un dimanche soir tout seul
dans sa cuisine c'est que c'est le port
c'est lui qui le portent mais il abat
une écrit tout seul et il a toute une
équipe avec lui des gens qui sont prêts
à apporter avec lui non madame r chance
de travailler difficile mais si lon
surtout à droite à droite quand même
l'homme le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il incarne enfin la
cinquième république tels que l'avs ou
du général de gaulle c'est un homme qui
porte des valeurs
monsieur fillon a détruit toutes les
valeurs qu'ils incarnaient
vassa nicolas sarkozy face à monsieur
juppé il alternait cette droiture et la
totalement mis à terre c'est pour ça que
j'ai pour moi c'est terminé il ne pourra
jamais ouvrir la bouche on regardera en
permanence la sphère pénélope dette est
la seule solution c'est nicolas dupont
aignan qui a toujours tenu la même ligne
politique qui la tiendra et vous invite
à regarder les sondages on est en train
de monter mathématiquement et vous
verrez on alice le graet chili ce
sondage on a eu le bret site
ah ben moi je peux dire qu'elles sont là
je suis pas un million
j'ai connu des actions c'est parce que
je sais pas ce que nicolas dupont aignan
et à 2% aux élections régionales on
mettait à 2% et j'ai fait 5,2 ap le
modem était à six et ils ont fait 3 donc
en réalité sur la je n'y crois pas mais
la réalité c'est qu'on a eu le bret site
on a eu la victoire de truffes on a eu
la victoire surprise de fillon on a eu
la victoire surprise de hamon eh bien on
aura la victoire surprise de nicolas
dupont aignan j'en suis totalement
convaincu vous les prophéties mais sur
wii ce que je voulais dire c'est que
finalement cette affaire fillon elle
symbolise et elle est révélatrice d'un
système politique qui est en train de
mourir simplement un système qui est
rejeté par la majorité des français qui
n'en peuvent plus rien d'une caste
politique qui s'est servi en des années
l'euthanasie elle n'est pas où il s'en
servir au lieu de servir l'intérêt
général
et c'est ça finalement là après le
principal enseignement donc ce système
doit tomber
quoi qu'il arrive avec ses abus et que
ces privilèges avec son indécence
puisque ce qui s'est passé confie avec
monsieur fillon s'est totalement
indécent au regard des difficultés que
les terminer juste ici puisque le front
national comme vous l'avez soulevé en
tout cas n'est pas un parti de droite
mais nous nous adressons à tous les
français quel qu'il soit à tous les
patriotes et moi je m'adresse
ouvertement aux adhérents des
républicains aux sympathisants aux
électeurs de droite qui se sentent
floués dans cette histoire est que
finalement qui ne veulent pas et que la
victoire de la gauche et qui veulent
porter une candidate capable de faire
gagner leurs idées qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent finalement ses électeurs ils
veulent le retour de l'autorité
ils veulent l'ordre pour tous ils
veulent la préservation de notre
identité et notamment nos racines
chrétiennes ils veulent que nos valeurs
républicaines et laïques soit respectée
ali veulent que le travail soit
récompensé la fraude sanctionnés ils
veulent aussi un principe de base la
priorité nationale que les français
soient les premiers services chez eux et
je leur dis donc à tous ses
sympathisants à tous ses électeurs que
la seule candidate capable de faire
gagner leurs valeurs et leur idée c'est
marine à la recherche vous coûter moi
c'est une droite - en tout cas un parti
patriotique dans lesquels moiré week-end
je ne me retrouve pas du tout le repli
identitaire ce n'est pas nos valeurs à
nous on a ici un repli identitaire
il faut une ouverture il faut
travailler avec l'europe et dans
l'europe il faut aujourd'hui un projet
fort et je pense que les républicains
encore leurs valeurs leur identité leur
programme et qu'ils sont au jour
d'aujourd'hui presse mobiliser d une
fracture entre cette élite
finalement cette petite caste d'élus des
républicains il est la base marine le
pen
les électeurs sincère je pense en
devenir c'est quand sa mère a été
décerné en même temps si vous prenez la
transparence si vous prenez si vous
donnez des leçons de transparence et
d'éthique je pense que votre parti très
mal très mal situés sur ce plan n'a donc
on arrête maintenant je vous rejoins sur
une seule chose c'est que aujourd'hui il
faut effectivement des candidats qu'ils
soient pas des candidats du système
parce qu'effectivement c'est quoi le
système le sérail politique entre fillon
et le sérail politique c'est-à-dire des
candidats qui sortent de sciences po et
de l'ena qui font un parcours d'attaché
parlementaire qui vont des cabinets et
que d'un coup se présentent sur des
listes et puis ensuite tous les
partisans sont capables milliards il
faut vraiment un renouvellement
politique qu'il passe temps des
l'éthique de la transparence des
nouvelles têtes
et puis aussi l'ouverture ça c'était
civils dont je fais partie excusez moi
je termine dont la dont la société
civile et je pense que les gens qui sont
dans la vraie vie qui ont vraiment
travaillé eux qui sont dans la vraie vie
qui ont pas des parcours de sérail
politique sans capacité de voir ce
qu'elle meilleur pour leur pays pour le
redresser et moi j'en cage incarne ce
style de candidats je le revendique et
je souhaite qu'on soit de plus en plus
nombreux dans ce schéma les françois
laramée travailliste la madame je vous
invite à démissionner des républicains
et à nous rejoindre parce que non vous
êtes en train de dénoncer des partis
politiques c'est pratique du mois moi ce
qui me dérange quand même c'est déjà
assisté à des lancements de casseroles
j'ai l'impression d'être dans l'émission
top chef
en fait cette campagne présidentielle
fait l'émission top chef maintenant il
serait peut-être pas mal c'est de parler
aux français qui sont en train de
souffrir parce qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui se passe on va une dame madame
pénélope fillon qui n'a jamais travaillé
qui a touché cinq mille euros en moyenne
par mois alors qu'à côté on a des
français qu'ils lèvent le matin qui vont
boulot qui ne peuvent pas payer la
maison de retraite de leurs parents qui
ne peuvent pas trouver des places de
crèche pour leurs enfants et qui voit
cet exemple là alors c'est sûr madame si
vous défendez cette position
là bas je vous invite à prendre une
carte chez nicolas dupont aignan et
république tout et vous savez car malade
de faire très envie là monsieur masson
nous a rejoint en tous cas sénateur de
moselle où il est au salon
je vais vous dire je ne vis pas tous les
tous les parlementaires je ne vise pas
les parlementaires républicains il ya
des gens très bien
je pense au sénateur jean paul emorine
en saône-et-loire quelqu'un de très bien
je pense à des conseillers
départementaux
madame rob lowe monsieur b coup sur
saône et loire qui sont des gens très
bien mais ce qu'il faut c'est leur
donner espoir à ces gens là parce que
quand vous allez sur le terrain vous
savez très bien
il faut pas être hypocrite les gens vous
disent quoi fillon c'est fini fillon
nous a trahis fillon croyant sa droiture
et on veut finalement à candidat qui va
incarner un changement politique
mais cette année mais l'espoir de
travailler sur le podium
cette séquence triste attendait celle
qu'on voit si résidentiel c'est un nom
moi c'est comme si un ou deux idées
dissolution pour la mais bien sûr la
jumelle et france 2 à une france forte
c'est pas forcément pas vous l'aurez pas
avec quelqu'un qui a des casseroles
derrière le projet la casserole mais
votre projet n'a rien eu lieu sur 15 et
delta position mais il atteint prochaine
pas forcément un carnet il est porté et
ben pas partie il par toute une équipe
c'est là qu'ils ont vraiment marre des
gens comme moi j'y fonce a fini le
président de la république c'est un
homme c'est un homme s'impose sur la
scène internationale j'étais à l'église
idées avec des projets c'est un avec des
comptines cirrhose ou une femme et là
pour le coup ils peuvent alors vous vous
êtes attaqués par vos détracteurs pour
en parler qui disent que vous voulez
défendre une france qui se replient sur
elles qui a peur de l'autre et c'est là
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous est ce
que c'est le genre de société que vous
voulez pour la france mais pas du tout
fait ce sont des caricatures et des
vieilles lunes
nous ne voulons pas une france barricadé
avec des barbelés jamais les frontières
mais c'est pas fermé des frontières la
frontière c'est pas un mur la frontière
c'est un filtre qui permet de contrôler
qui ont fait rentrer et ou pas voilà
c'est la frontière ce qui permet de
protéger notamment des djihadistes qui
viennent sur nos territoires
la frontière c'est ce qui permet pour
l'instant ça te met en place était déjà
122 mètres passe le protectionnisme
intelligent de faire en sorte que nos
entreprises nos emplois soient protégés
c'est tout la frontière qui nous permet
de faire en sorte que les français
deviennent pas les esclaves des qatari
et des chinois c'est ça la frontière et
jeu
tiens à le rappeler quand même parce que
c'est une évidence dans 95% des pays du
monde il y a des frontières
il ya des frontières il ya une monnaie
nationale car ce sont des éléments
indispensables liberté du peuple à sa
souveraineté
le front national parle d'un parti
patriote qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
les autres ne le sont pas déjà
vous pensez que les républicains au labo
la france merci mme thibault est debout
la france sont des patriotes
évidemment il ya des patriotes je dirais
dans tous les courants politiques et la
majorité des patries et d'ailleurs ne
sont pas encartés il faut le faut le
savoir et marine le pen elle ce qu'elle
veut c'est rassembler tous les patriotes
il ya des patriotes qui vont venir nous
rejoindre avant le premier tour il a
d'autres qui vont venir entre les deux
tours et la dôle qui composeront cette
grande majorité présidentielle patriots
après la victoire de marine le pen est
évidemment qu'elle tend la main à debout
la france à nicolas dupont aignan à des
gens comme rory guaino ou aider à des
patriotes de gauche qui pourront
évidemment nous rejoindre vous sentez
patriote je pense qu'on est tous
patriotes que cette façon je ne
s'approprient ce mot mais plus il ya de
gens qui défend le patriotisme plus je
suis heureux on a une pendant trente ans
une politique était anti patriotique non
plus il ya de gens qui défendent la
ligne patriote nous je suis en tout cas
je pense qu'on pourra gagner l'élection
présidentielle au 2e tour qu'en
rassemblant les 10 millions de français
qui permettent de faire plus de 50%
et si je défends nicolas dupont aignan
c'est que je suis convaincu que s'il au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle il pourra rassembler ces
gens là contrairement à marine le pen
c'est ce qui fait notre différence
je pense qu elle ne le pourra pas parce
que c'est une histoire d'esprit et de
sentiments voilà les gens ont toujours
un tir sentiment qui fait ils ne sont
pas convaincus par l'élection de marine
le pen
mais ça c'est un débat est en tout cas à
l'étranger dorcel vous permettre à des
projets qui n'ont pas ce ressentiment me
dévisageait 35% des français qui s'en
vouloir
je vous en prie vouloir minimiser je
dirais le talent et je dirais
l'envergure nicolas dupont aignan et
concevoir qu'à comme une dynamique
manifeste autour de la candidature de
marine et que probablement c'est elle
qui sera au second tour qui peut
l'emporter équipe justement faire
triompher les idées que nous avons en
commun madame le pen est à 30 % dans les
sondages peut-être mais la 35 ans nathan
on vote ce qui veut dire qu'il ya quand
même une barrière nicolas dupont aignan
est aujourd'hui à peu près à 5%
mais il a 21 % d'intentions de vote
c'est le candidat qui a le moins dans
les sondages mais tient le plus
d'intentions de vote ça c'est ça qui
peut définir arrière les plafonds de
verre
oui mais où il ya sarah chalke rg
nicolaj la conversion sa dauphine sophie
riez m 70% des électeurs de lierre la
ville dont il est le maire vote pour lui
ça dépasse lumière l'étrange vous n'avez
pas cet exemple au front national air
n'est pas la france allégement bien
qu'on parle un petit peu d'économie de
chômage en fait à lire vos programmes en
gros en tout cas les programmes des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle où
rien de vraiment très original pour
relancer l'économie
en gros on baisse les charges c'est la
seule solution à l'achat c'est pas la
seule solution mais cette charge c'est
une c'est quand même le monstre du loch
ness 1 ça fait des années qu'on en
parlait depuis des années qu'on
n'applique pas donc maintenant il faut
agir
tant qu'on n'aura pas baisser les
charges sur les entreprises on ne pourra
pas créer de la croissance et de
l'emploi
c'est le même ce gouvernement s'y
atteler avec le cic n'a pas vraiment
bienvenu que le cic s'est pas tu ne sais
pas une baisse de charge s'est hissée
c'est une manière très grand rôle de
maître de la trésorerie de côté et
surtout bénéficié aux grandes
entreprises et très peu ou même les pme
c'est comme 90% des entreprises en
france il faut penser à elle donc
maintenant pour les entreprises toutes
catégories il faut une baisse de charges
massives
sans cela les pme qui créent l'emploi
qui vont créer de la richesse ne
pourront pas pérennisé en france et
c'est que c'est la recette miracle il
n'y a pas que ça pour pour il faut aussi
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
est clairement le programme que nous
défendons
instaurée afin d'infléchir 40 milliards
40 milliards sur les entreprises 10
milliards sur les ménages pour pouvoir
d'achat on a les moyens si on réduit le
déficit et qui ont réduit la dette
publique quand même assez amusant de
voir celles et ceux qui ne l'ont conduit
dans le mur qui ont colmant ravagé notre
économie voilà qui sont jeudi
responsables nous 7 millions de chômeurs
2 9 millions de pauvres qui ont
délocalisé
comme c'est pas permis qui donnent
aujourd'hui des leçons et qui
m'attendent et il ya des solutions vous
allez voir ce qu'on va voir
bon la réalité c'est que françois fillon
et ses amis sont totalement disqualifié
pour faire un projet économique pour
redresser notre pays
la réalité c'est bien vu que le front
national proposait de lui un plan de
réindustrialisation de servier au cours
ça veut dire quoi ça nous il n'y a pas
que ça déjà il faut faire que je dirais
quelque chose qui n'a pas été fait
depuis longtemps qui a fait ses preuves
c'est retrouver le patriotisme
économique tard c'est quoi le
patriotisme patriotisme économique c'est
un grand plan ce que disait c'est un
grand plan de réindustrialisation déjà
c'est le protectionnisme intelligent
donc faire en sorte que nos emplois nos
industries nos entreprises soient
protégées
c'est faire en sorte aussi qu'il n'y ait
plus de travailleurs détachés pour que
les français est une priorité à l'emploi
toutes ces mesures là et le insisté
notamment sur le fabriqué en france qui
va permettre justement de retrouver de
la croissance toutes ces mesures là qui
vont nous permettre ensuite de sauver
nos emplois
nicolas dupont aignan oui patriotisme
économique des formes patriotisme
économique c'est à dire de valoriser
déjà l'industrie française et défendre
déjà l'industrie française
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
se rendre compte qu'elle est en train de
mourir moi je pense à alstom à belfort
je pense à areva qui va être dans une
situation difficile tout ça pour quoi
parce qu'en réalité on n'a plus de
vision industrielle en france et qu'on
l'a soumis aux pouvoirs financiers tels
que le fera un monsieur macro qui est
l'enfant spirituel de de françois
hollande et de giscard de valéry giscard
d'estaing dont jacques chirac disait
exactement je sais quel parti de
l'étranger et le vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est il faut incarner et
c'est la dernière chance à cette
élection présidentielle
une une candidature patriotique qui
défendra l'industrie française car tout
repose là-dessus on
c'est à dire la suppression de la
directive sur les travailleurs détachés
le protectionnisme qui permet
naturellement d'éviter à ce que des
produits qu'ils soient fait de l'
esclavage moderne des pays de l'est ou
de l'asie puisse être vendue en france
où tu ne respectent pas l'environnement
c'est financer la recherche
c'est valoriser la production française
dans les marchés publics
et puis surtout c'est aussi permettre de
relancer la consommation
en 90 ans la retraite notamment des
personnes qui sont le plus dans le
besoin de 100 euros par mois
c'est en diminuant l'impôt sur le revenu
et c'est en redonnant confiance aux
français c'est une vraie réalité et je
pense une confiance qui doit aussi se
retrouver dans le travail où il faut
mettre en avant le bien être et non pas
seulement le consumérisme le temps passe
vite
ce grand rassemblement de patriotes que
nous appelons de nos voeux ce que vient
de dire maxime thibeault fait partie des
144 engagement présidentielle de marine
aïe vous fait un appel du pied à sans
arrêt sur l'aura sur l'europe c'est
peut-être la chose qui vous différencie
un peu tous les trois et pourtant dans
vos dans les trois programmes aussi
finalement vos trois candidats et date
parle d'europe des nations ça veut dire
quoi
anr chance pour vous l'europe des
nations il faut défendre l'europe et
l'europe des nations c'est une europe
qui sache travailler en un vrai
partenariat qui nous la place rouge où
la place de la france doit être quand
même de plus en plus forte
c'est une europe où on doit pouvoir
dépasser effectivement pouvoir avoir un
libre échange en dépassant nos
frontières mais en faisant légèrement
c'est à dire que nous nos entreprises
contrairement à ce que propose le front
national elles ont toute leur place dans
la mondialisation
il faut juste pouvoir leur permettre de
travailler sereinement équitablement par
rapport aux autres pays
ça veut dire que on trappe on parlait
des travailleurs détachés au jour
d'aujourd'hui un travailleurs détachés
qui vient travailler en france d'accord
à travail égal salaire égal et cherche
sociale égale aussi donc les conditions
d'un vote les mêmes pour tout le monde
et pour les pays alors c'est l'europe
sociale et l'europe des 27 c'est vrai
qu'elle a du mal à fonctionner et la
france doit vraiment
avoir toute sa place et avoir des
propositions à faire pour avoir sa place
notamment économiques
en quelques secondes on fait un
référendum c'est ça quand on arrive au
pouvoir si on est au front national a
pour ou contre l'europe
alors déjà le premier acte de marine
quand elle sera élue présidente de la
république au lendemain elle va
directement à bruxelles donc pour
négocier avec la commission et pour le
retour de notre souveraineté budgétaire
monétaire et territoriales berne a signé
des traités
on a signé des traités vous avez un
traité ça se déchire sa se remanie et
puis c'est le peuple qui tranche
voilà à partir du moment où le peuple
français a décidé que marine est
président de la république il aura
validé ce programme pour retrouver notre
liberté notre souveraineté si la
commission accepte dans ce cas nous
retrouvons nous pouvons construire une
europe des nations libres et
indépendantes
s'il n'accepte pas il y aura un
référendum dans lequel donc marine le
pen est de montrer aux français donc de
sortir de cette europe technocratique
qui nous impose finalement l'austérité
qui nous impose des normes et qui nous
impose des milandes vous êtes un peu sur
la même ligne moi j'ai 26 ans et quand
j'aurai 50 ans je veux pas vivre dans
une france le cost du tiers-monde est la
seule solution c'est de redéfinir des
grands projets européens
c'est à dire la conquête de l'espace la
conquête des fonds marins des fronts des
fonds marins tard dans la recherche en
termes de santé énergétique et pour cela
l'europe démocratique ça ne fonctionne
pas ces normes financières qu'il est
finie la taille des pots de yaourt
plutôt que de s'occuper des grands
projets industriels et moi je préfère
revenir une europe des nations on
coopère comme on l'avait fait airbus
avec les a ils ont défini des grands
projets et ans - va emmener notre
jeunesse
on va donner un espoir est l'incarnation
de l'espoir en tout cas c'est ce que je
veux faire à 26 ans c'est ce que fait
nicolas dupont aignan c'est pour ça
qu'on veut une europe des communautés de
nation à leur chance un petit mot de
conclusion vous sentez comment la cette
fin de campagne parce que finalement ça
va être très très quoi ça va être écrit
comme moi je suis je suis sereine parce
que je sais qu'on a un excellent
programme
pour nous la droite et le centre pour
redresser la france est enclenché les
réformes qui sont nécessaires pour
demain même avec françois fillon en
grosse difficulté même avec françois
fillon mais on va laisser la justice
faire son travail c'est pas question
d'un plan b pour l'instant pour
l'instant il n'ya pas question de pombie
diamant rien non il n'a pas et bien on
va continuer à suivre cette campagne on
a l'occasion bien sûr de débattre de
nombreux thèmes a dit si le premier tour
de la présidentielle mais pour l'instant
on arrive au terme déjà de cette
émission merci à vous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en tout cas je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
et sur notre page facebook la semaine
prochaine et bien puisqu'on se demander
aujourd'hui où elle est la droite est
bien on se demandera ou voix la gauche
mais tout de suite place à l'info
régionale avec elle a besoin et puis
tout de suite après dimanche en
politique continue francis le pemier
reçoit aujourd'hui françois bayrou bon
appétit et bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]